hi i'm tom sherlock been giving a talk
this morning about planetary image
processing using the Wolfram language
and its how to import stacked and
statistically processed data coming from
Telescope and imaging planets
do we have any professional scientists
or astronomers here like you well don't
worry I'm not one either I'm a user
interface developer here at Wolfram
research but anyway today I'm not going
to be speaking about software
development I'm going to be speaking or
about features that I've developed in
Mathematica I'm going to be speaking
about my hobby which is astronomy and in
particular Astro photography and one of
the things that I've been doing a bit
over the last year and sometime before
then
is taking pictures of planets and this
is a little different than what people
normally think of as Astro photography
and it requires a different sort of data
reduction and so I thought I'd go
through some of the ways that
Mathematica and the Wolfram language
help me out in this so let's get started
here and I'm gonna have I'm gonna try to
time the so I have time for questions at
the end so that's the way it's gonna
work anyway so the abstract is basically
a summary here and the Wolfram language
is a really great platform for doing
stuff related to astronomy because it
contains a great deal of astronomical
data and it also contains very powerful
image processing and data reduction
features which in particular come in
handy when doing the sort of work so I'm
going to talk about some of these things
and show how I can take you know a
series of really fuzzy grainy images and
get something that looks kind of
reasonable now when people normally
think of ask photography they think of a
little different sort of operation and
I'm just gonna I'm not going to talk
about this in depth because I talked
about it in different talks before and
I'm going to just describe how people
normally do ask photography and they're
typically pictures of astronomical
objects are typically imaged from
fairly long exposures one to five
minutes typically to maximize the
signal-to-noise ratio
the issue with imaging game objects is
trying to separate the signal from the
noise so everything that you do with
like normal ash photography is trying to
maximize the signal and so for that
reason you need a fairly long exposure
which therefore requires that your
telescope be accurately aligned with the
Earth's polar axis and then on top of
that you need to use some sort of
guiding operation either manually like
they did in the old days or basically
closed-loop guiding where you have an
additional telescope on top of your
telescope pointing towards the star
which picks up variations and in the
position of the star which is due to
errors and the gear train on your on
your drive and then it feeds correction
pulses back to the drive so you can stay
locked on to an object for a fairly long
time if you want to take a picture of a
larger object like for instance the
Andromeda galaxy you have to do
depending on what sort of equipment you
have you typically have to do that in
pieces and make a mosaic and one of the
more tedious things that people don't
realize is if you want to get really
good data you have to take not just
images of the object which are the light
frames but you have to take a series of
other frames which measure the the noise
that's present in in your your CCD
camera and so these encompass things
like dark frames flat frames which help
you subtract off light fall-off and dust
on your CCD bias frames which just
measure the readout noise of your CCD
and dark flat frames but we're not going
to talk about that today we're going to
talk about planetary Astro photography
and the big difference between diffuse
object astrophotography and
photography of solar system objects is
the planets are much much smaller and
brighter than nebula clusters and
galaxies and the largest and brightest
solar system objects you might image the
Sun and the moon are still small
compared to some diffuse objects and
give you an example of this the angular
diameter of the moon is is about half a
degree twenty nine point five five five
minutes but the andromeda galaxy which
is one of the brightest galaxies in the
sky besides the Milky Way is over three
degrees so the moon is 1/6 the size of
the Andromeda galaxy the Andromeda
galaxy you can actually see it if you go
out on a fairly dark night and just look
in the right spot of the sky and you'll
see a blur there which was in ancient
times was known as kind of a little
cloud but it was actually the core of
the galaxy in order to image the entire
galaxy you have to take a long exposure
so so the difference is with solar
system objects instead of a dozen
exposures you typically take hundreds or
thousands of exposures and there each of
them is very short so the fact that
you're taking a very short exposure kind
of negates the effect of the planet
moving around because of errors in your
your gear train it for the same reason
it doesn't require careful alignment of
the telescope or manual or closed-loop
guiding the drift effects can be
canceled out by software operations and
I'll show you how that's done since the
objects are typically small there's no
need to mosaic except in cases like
where you're taking wide-angle pictures
of the moon then you will have to do
that and noise again is not a really a
big problem because the image is the
large number of images tends to
compensate for this problem and the
sensor that you use unlike in the
of the fuse object astrophotography
doesn't generally need to be cooled the
camera I have to which I take pictures
of dim objects has a thermoelectric
cooling system on it and and more
expensive cameras have more
sophisticated systems where you can
actually pump water through the camera
so you can do quite a lot with just a
webcam this is a logitech quickcam 3000
that I've repurposed for my hobby here
and I just adapted it like this so it'll
fit in the back of my telescope you
don't even have to do that I've also
taken semi ok pictures by just holding
my iPhone up to the eyepiece of the
telescope and just kind of kind of
having to swim around there but that
it's not that big of a problem because
you you track these things and you're
going to compensate for it so let me
show you some of the techniques I used
so there's a workflow the first part of
course is the collecting the images and
this is the part that's done with heavy
expensive fragile equipment and
computers all done in near pitch
darkness but after you get done with
that part you do the software workflow
which is importing the images then you
want to sort them out
because you get some clinker images and
you have to have a systematic way of
finding bad images now with with a short
number of exposures you can just find
you know which pictures are fuzzy or or
bad or smeared and just eliminate them
but for planetary when you're dealing
with thousands of images you you have to
have some sort of systematic way so that
requires some image processing and data
processing then you need to align the
images stacking the images is a
statistical process which smears out the
noise and extracts the signal and then
typically you have to stretch the images
so that the
the data is is more visible and then do
final processing which includes
sharpening and deconvolution and the
Wolfram language helps you do all these
things very efficiently so let's talk
about importing images one the powerful
features the Wolfram language is is easy
to get data into it and lots of
different things for instance you can
here I'm just enumerated in the
directory and I'm gonna import some some
Jupiter images now these weren't
actually taken of the same in the same
sequence they just had these images
lying around so so if they were in the
same sequence they would look more like
these two guys here but I just wanted to
show how how you can easily bring in
ping images right into Mathematica if
you're familiar with Astro photography
and astronomy in general you probably
will be more used to this format the
fits file format which is used is more
important for scientific work because it
contains a lot more data and it contains
scientific data that you will need for
instance information about the camera
and the exposure and calibration and
stuff and we can bring that stuff right
into Mathematica too however it's a
little bit different because it comes in
as an association so I'm going to have
to untangle this stuff but that's easy
to do so I'll bring in some fit images
and and there you can see my fit
sequence of course you can't see
anything unless you have a really good
eye here because Jupiter's is pretty dim
there but if you just want to see what
they look like you can apply image
adjust to this list and this will give
us a quick idea of what what we got
and so you can see the images here I
don't know why this one has a bad
exposure but it doesn't really matter
because we since we take so many images
we're going to kind of identify clinkers
and filter them out and and everything
kind of smoothes out and so another way
you might want to collect data is with
video and this is probably the simplest
way because a video camera as like the
one I showed you you can just plug in
and capture video from it and this also
has the advantage is that it collects a
very rapidly collects a large number of
very short exposures which is good
because as I said that will negate the
effects of periodic error and your gear
train so I'm going to import a video
file here this is just an AVI file and
it's generally best to import
uncompressed video so what that's the
path and then this is a Mac doesn't
normally deal with avi so it converts it
to QuickTime and this is just a list of
all the frames it's it's a little dumb
but you'll see later on that this is
kind of a useful thing this is just a
list of all the frames a short form of
it so this sequence was 1200 frames and
let's just bring in the first 10 frames
as kind of a short image sequence so it
just pulled that in and now we can just
see the jupiter images off the video and
there's one of them and here I can just
flip through these and you can see that
even though the exposure is short its
jupiter still dancing around a little
bit and that's because of the
atmospheric and
ability and it's hard to it's hard to
compensate for that the we're gonna try
aligning the images but still after you
line them you'll still see some
distortion so I'm working on that for
next year's dog so then after you get
the images into into Mathematica you
need to call them and basically you
filter out the bad ones and so this
determine this comes into the question
of what's a bad image and this is
actually not a trivial thing there's a
lot of methods for image quality
assessment and a lot of literature on
that and generally it's its assessment
where you give it a perfect image and
then you give it a corrupted image and
then you determine the quality based on
comparing the two but that's not what we
have here this is called the blind image
quality assessment so basically looking
at an image without any reference image
and determining what the quality is so
the good news is we don't need anything
super accurate we just need to be able
to determine what the relative quality
of the images are so for that I like to
use a key tense which is a vector field
by taking the gradient over the image of
intensity at as a function of its
position in the image and so we can
easily calculate that in Mathematica by
just taking the mean of a gradient
filter on the image and flattening it
out and just taking the mean of that
data so if we do that I'm not going to
calculate this because we're running a
little short here if you sort the images
by the akha tense and you can easily do
that with sort by and then you do a list
plot by applying a cue tents to the
sorted image sequence you'll see that
the the quality the images varies
there's some some crummy ones down here
and some
good ones and there's different ways you
can measure a cue tents and different
packages you know commercial packages
have lets you choose the algorithm and
it doesn't really change the shape of
this curve that much it might shift it
up and down you can use the Sobel edge
filtering to do that but but basically
all we're really interested here is the
relative accuracy the relative so what I
then do is I figure how many I'm going
to eliminate so I'm going to call about
twenty percent and and then I will take
my best frames are everything but those
twenty percent so take largest by a cue
gents
of the frame count so if I do that then
we need to align the images so the
alignment is also done using image
processing techniques for instance
here's the best frame in our sequence
and you can see it right there still
doesn't look that great but that's the
best we have and the way I align them is
normally I could use the alignment image
processing alignment functions built
into Mathematica but those key off of
features and you can see we don't really
have too many features here it really
the only the big feature we have is the
planetary disc so the best thing we can
do with data of this quality is to just
find the center of the disk and that's
easy to do because we can binarize the
image and then do component measurements
on it and that will determine what the
and that will give us the the center of
the image you can see I've drawn a disk
around Jupiter and the center of the
disk is the center of the image so then
given that I can write a little function
and here this uses parallel processing
capabilities of Mathematica it does so
here it's taking its morphologically
binarized images after adjusting it it
does component measurements to determine
the centroid and then it does a parallel
map on the center points for each image
it does an image pad on it and that
shifts it to a target position and the
target position I'm picking is the
center of the frame the target X and y
equals image dimensions so the best
frame divided by 2 and then I
so the aligned frames are aligned
planetary images and this is all in in
the notebook that you can you can
download so once I do that I get a
series of image you can see the Jupiter
here has been shifted to the center of
the frame and it's not jumping around as
law a lot as much but you can still see
it's kind of moving around in size and
shape and right now with the techniques
I'm using I can't really get around that
but that's kind of ok because it all
averages out in the end as I said if you
want you can do further alignment using
the alignment functions and if you have
very high quality images you can
you can further do that should divide
this up into more slides so you can use
image align but that that works best if
you have very visible planetary features
okay so after you get the images aligned
then it's actually pretty simple so what
I do is I basically just convert them to
data and just take a mean or a median of
all the images so that basically since
they're all stacked on top of each other
you can imagine the image stack as a
several array a bunch of arrays and each
column a column of pixels you're taking
the the mean or the median of that and
I'm not going to do that right now
because it takes a few minutes and we're
running out of time but this is the
result here and then you need to stretch
it and the reason for that is
astronomical images quite often
concentrate the data into just a small
fraction of the range of values that
could be so here you can see the RGB
channels are all concentrated in the
range 0 to 0.4 so we can easily stretch
this and this will bring up the image so
now you can see a lot more color detail
on the planet and then the final thing
you need to do is you need to do some
sort of image processing to remove the
fuzziness and fuzziness is generally
described by something called the point
spread function and for some images I've
talked about this in earlier talks it's
possible to estimate the point spread
function by just examining the image but
we
can't really do that now we could do
that if there were stars in the image
that were were fairly distinct and then
we picked them out and and then figure
out how they deviated from a point but
we can't do that right now because they
don't have any stars in the image so
we're going to just guess and a good
guess is a Gaussian matrix and you can
see the point spread function kind of
looks like this so this would be a star
in the center which has been blurred out
and see what that looks like a little
more clearly it's something that looks
like this so then we need to assume that
the image is the convolution of this
function with the real image and so we
can use our image deconvolution
functionality to remove this and y r-d
convolution is a spectral deconvolution
method and it tends to be pretty good
because one problem with deconvolution
methods is they tend to introduce
artifacts and so that's our final image
and you can start seeing some some
details cloud structures on the planet
this is not bad considering how bad the
initial images were you can also do more
sophisticated techniques like one
technique which is favored in astronomy
is is something called maximum entropy
deconvolution and I will and this is an
iterative method and this is basically
came out of radio astronomy but it works
good for visible images too I'm not
going to go into this too carefully but
this is based on some some NASA code and
you can look at this later the good
thing about this is it doesn't introduce
too many artifacts and it converges
rather slowly so you can see what you're
getting pretty quick preed generally now
one problem with dealing with large
number of
images is you tend to run out of memory
especially if you're dealing with
thousands and thousands of frames so a
smart way to do this is to process
things in chunks and the Wolfram
language easily lets you do that because
you can take the frame list that we saw
before you can partition it into chunks
of 32 frames and then stack each one of
those chunks and then stack the final
list this takes a little bit longer but
you don't run out of memory and your
computer doesn't crash which is always
an advantage and so here's some quick
examples that's the scope I used to take
all these pictures it's not a big scope
and if I import the stuff going to and
so here's a series of frames this is
just a few of the frames but you can see
one of the artifacts this is not an
artifact on the planet but that's an
artifact on my CCD camera you can see
that stick stain still it's a dust blob
enemy of astrophotographers the world
over and so that if I stack that and
it's going to quickly go through this so
I'm gonna stack it and then do the image
processing and rotation you can see the
final image here which shows a lot of
detail on the planet's surface including
the Great Red Spot and to show you that
we know that that's actually the right
place I asked Wolfram Alpha to compute
the position of the Great Red Spot on
the date that that image was the date
and time that image was taken and
hopefully
get some results here so you can see
it's in this same position and as a
little aside you can also see I actually
took several sequences and and you can
see the planets rotating so Jupiter
rotates once every nine hours so in
between the time I took the first
sequence in the second sequence it had
shifted over a little bit and people
with more patience and time than I have
actually take movies of this and just
showed you do rotating all the way
around so any questions